Hello everyone. Um, I am back for yet
another video and this one is going to
be about geospatial indexes. Um, if
you're wondering what a geospatial index
is, let me uh give you an example of
something. Let's imagine that we're on a
website. I won't really talk about which
ones, but you see something that tells
you that they're um, you know, 5 mile
radius that are interested in you. Well,
um, the only way they can actually do
that, uh, in a decently efficient way is
using something like a geospatial index.
So, we're going to go ahead and talk
about how those work and break it down
for you. All righty. Geospatial indexes.
What are they? Well, basically, in a ton
of modern day applications, there's some
sort of need to be able to do the
following access pattern. We want to
take one given point, so maybe like a
coordinate, like a latitude and a
longitude, and find all of the other
points in the database of perhaps a
certain type that are within a certain
distance of it, probably by radius. So,
examples of this happening are Uber um
in terms of, you know, finding a nearby
driver, Yelp in terms of finding nearby
restaurants, and Tinder in terms of
finding nearby potential dating
partners. Um as we know um querying in a
database can be done with an index and
that's kind of there to speed up both
you know normal queries and range
queries over one given column. However
um with geoloccation data we have to use
something a little bit different or at
least make a modification to the data
itself in order to use indexes the same
way as before. This is where geospatial
indexes come in and I'll explain those
now. So what's the problem with
coordinate data? Why can't we just use a
typical index? Well, coordinates are
typically expressed by a latitude
longitude tupil. So, as you can see, if
we imagine latitude and longitude on
this cartisian plane where latitude and
longitude are each kind of one axis of
it, we have all of these points. Okay.
So, now let's imagine that we want to
find all of the points within some
distance of that yellow highlighted
point. So, that would be those two
points in the circle there. Well,
basically, what can we do? Imagine we
had a traditional database and we have
these two columns for each point,
latitude and longitude. Well, I guess if
we had an index on either latitude or
longitude, what we could do is just go
ahead and basically say, okay, uh say
the distance was 5 miles, um let's find
all the points with a latitude, you
know, within like the 5 mile equivalent
of that. And then, you know, once we
have all those points, we can go ahead
and filter them out. Well, the problem
is in the real world there's a ton of
points that are going to be within just,
you know, a certain latitude value, but
not within also the right longitude
value. So only having an index on one of
these two fields is very inefficient
because it means that we find all these
points but then we still have to go
ahead and filter a ton of other points
down and you know that could be millions
even perhaps uh tens of millions of
points that we would basically just have
to invalidate by using some sort of um
you know like cartisian equation for
finding the distance between those two
points and it would be super
inefficient. It's basically just a full
table scan. So obviously that's not
going to work. So, what can we do that
would actually take advantage of an
index and allow us to quickly find all
the points within a certain distance of
one point? Um, obviously we're going to
have to look for a better solution here.
So, what we do instead is called
geohashing. So, geocaching, um, this is
kind of like a pretty simple overview of
it. This isn't exactly how geohashing
works, but it's kind of the way that I'm
going to summarize it. And then, you
know, if you do any research in the
future, hopefully that'll make more
sense to you. But basically the gist of
geoh hashing is this. Imagine a map of
the earth which I'll just you know let's
imagine it was a 2D plane right here
again split into that longitude and lat
latitude. You take every single section
divide them in some sort of way
hopefully relatively evenly or maybe by
population or something like that and
mark each section with a letter or a
number. So just a character for now.
We'll just call that the geohash of the
section. So as you can see at imagine
this is what um the entire world looks
like the whole map. So you know we might
have Asia in the you know the K and L
section uh the US might be in the G&H
section because that's going to be at
least in the maps that I look on on the
western part. Um so the point is though
that we have this initial divide of the
map but obviously this doesn't really
describe uh areas particularly
precisely. it just you know creates this
map into huge chunks of you know massive
geography. So what we can actually do is
imagine I have this portion up here with
uh the label letter A. What I'm going to
do is divide A into a bunch of
subcategories. So imagine we zoomed in
on A. Now the view would actually look
like this. So we take A which is a
rectangle and we divide it into all
these sub regions. And so the point of
each sub region is that every single sub
region is its parent region concatenated
with one more character. And each of the
sub regions are unique in terms of their
strength.
So this is going to you know continue
downwards to a really really small size
of you know region. So I obviously have
a depth of two here but you know I could
have a depth of three. I could have a
depth of four. And every single time you
just go ahead and take that parent node
and then split it into a bunch of mini
chunks, which again you just add an
additional unique character for each of
those subchunks.
So let's think about what that actually
does. Basically, as the length of the
geo hash increases, the size of the
bounding box of the geohash decreases.
So you can see on this chart to the
right, we have all of these geohash
lengths and the corresponding size of
the bounding box or at least an
approximation of the size of the
bounding box. So basically now what we
have are we have all these big regions
and then all these sub regions of the
bigger regions where all the sub regions
are the bigger region concatenated with
some string. Why does this work really
well? Well, it all kind of pertains to
the fact that when you take all of that
um all of the geohashes like in total
and you order them, it means that
similar points are going to be right
next to one another in that ordering. So
let's actually think about that. So this
is kind of going to be the entire
process of geospatial indexing right
here and it's kind of based off that
whole geohash idea. So if you recall
both B trees and LSM trees with the SS
tables allow us to execute really fast
range queries based on an index field.
So imagine here that the index field is
going to actually be a geohash. It means
that geohashes that are next to each
other are probably going to be very
close to one another in proximity in the
actual world if they're next to one
another in the index. So let's say now
that we have a given point and we want
to actually go ahead and find the points
near it in our geospatial index. The
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to take our point which is
probably a latl long coordinate and
convert it to a geohash and there are
services to do this for us. Then what we
want to go ahead and do is actually
figure out the size of the geohash depth
that encapsulates the distance from the
point that we want. So say, you know, we
want to find um all points within a few
miles. You know, we could go ahead here
and say, oh, maybe depth 5 looks good
for us because, you know, it's 4.9 km
squared. Probably most of the points
that we want are going to be within the
same geo hash of depth 5, but we'll
we'll talk about that uh in a second
more. So, so then we're going to take
our geo hash of the point that we're
looking at and truncate it to the proper
depth because we're going to go ahead
and assume basically that all of the
points that we're looking for are going
to be within that bigger geohash that is
going to encapsulate all of the nearby
points with the appropriate size. And
then finally, once we have that um
bigger depth, we can go ahead and use
our index and execute a range query to
go ahead and quickly find all of the
points inside of the bigger geohash. And
then once we get all those points, we
probably have to go ahead and actually,
you know, filter a few of them because
obviously the size of the bounding box
isn't perfect. But it just, you know,
greatly limits the field of points that
we have to look at in order to see which
ones to uh go ahead and check, but I'm
actually going to provide an example of
this because I know that was all kind of
abstract.
Okay, so imagine we want to find all
points that are less than a kilometer
from this random latitude and longitude.
Um, so the first thing we're going to do
is get the geo hash of that. I'm
assuming that, you know, there's just
some API you can call to do that. And
uh, that's not actually the real geohash
of the point. I just made it up, but
whatever. So, first of all, imagine we
get this geohash. Then what we're going
to do is get a proper bounding box. So,
we're going to go ahead and say, okay,
well, the geohash of, you know, length 5
has a size 4.9 km squared. So if that's
the case, all of the points that we
want, which are, you know, within a
kilometer, are probably going to be in
the corresponding length 5 geocash. So
all we're going to do is now truncate
our original geohash to length 5 um and
look at all points in 91 VZ6 because
that's truncated to length 5. So now
take a look at the diagram on the right.
Basically, we have our original point
which was 91 VZ62Q.
um we have its bounding geohash which is
91 VZ62. Basically, you just take away
the Q. And then if you take away the two
there, we have 91 VZ6 which encapsulates
all of that. Um, keep in mind that, like
I said, even though we might just be
looking at 91 VZ6 here, in reality, if
90 if you know the point we were looking
at was really close to the border of 91
VZ6, then maybe we'd have to look at a
couple more neighboring nearby bounding
boxes in order to find all of the
points. So, probably, you know, maybe
like nine in total because you would
want to look at the top one, the top
left, the left, the bottom left, bottom,
bottom right, right, and top right. But
anyway, for now, let's just simplify it
and say we're going to be looking at the
one with the proper depth. So that's
going to be 91 VZ6.
We know now that because of how
geohashes work that basically any single
point inside of a geohash, so any single
sub region inside of a region is going
to have a lexic uh lexographically
greater ordering than it, right? So
every single point inside of 91 VZ6 is
going to be greater than 91 VZ6 when all
of those strings are sorted. And we also
know that imagine there was another box
uh on the same level as 91 VZ6. So like
think of them as siblings called 91 VZ7.
We know that the second a point is you
know greater to or equal than 91 VZ7,
it's no longer in the 91 VZ6 subbox. So
what this means is that we can go ahead
and execute a range query on our index
saying give us all the points that lie
between 91 VZ6 and 91 VZ7. So this is a
super quick thing. If we using SS
tables, those are going to be sorted and
we can go ahead and perform a binary
search really easily and get the bounds
of that range query. And then the same
goes for a B tree which also allows you
to perform that read in logarithmic
time.
As a result though, since obviously
these boxes aren't like a perfectly
tailored size for us, we may have to
filter down the results of the actual
range query a little bit. But just
compared to an index on either the
latitude or the longitude, this is
hugely efficient and much much faster.
Okay, so let's talk about geospatial
indexes in a distributed setting.
Obviously, in reality, there's probably
going to be a ton of data points. If
you're Tinder or you're Uber, you have a
ton of cars, a ton of users, and uh you
know, a ton of people looking for
potential dates. And as a result, you
probably can't store all those on one
machine. So obviously, these are going
to have to be partitioned somehow. The
good thing is that geospatial indexes
are actually really easy to partition
cuz you can just basically go ahead and
take any region and say, "Okay, plop
this region and all of its sub regions
accordingly onto one node." and then you
know so say that's going to be like the
New York region and then I'll go ahead
and say okay take the you know the box
that contains Pennsylvania and all of
the sub Pennsylvania nodes and put that
on another region. So basically this
this kind of like tree structure of
having all these sub regions makes it so
that it's super easy to go ahead and
partition a geospatial index and put um
the data for one area on a different
node than another area which is great.
And then obviously you can do stuff like
replication and all of that.
Okay. In practice, how do geospatial
indexes actually look? What type of
hardware are they used on? Well, it
seems like for ride sharing companies
like Lyft, Lyft tends to use something
like Reddus for geospatial indexes
because they actually have a service
that builds it into Reddus. And um that
means that they're probably going to be
kept in memory and really fast so that
you can constantly query um the service
in order to see your distance from the
driver, see the driver's current
location, etc., etc., which is great.
And then in addition, Uber kind of has
created their own type of geospatial
index, which is very similar to
geohashing, but as opposed to doing it
with um rectangular boxes, it actually
uses hexagons. Uh the reason they do
this is so that you know if you say uh
from this given point I want to find all
points within a certain radius. Um the
kind of a hexagon with a bunch of
surrounding hexagons is a lot better for
resembling a circle and that way you can
kind of more easily check other hexagon
cells to see relevant points. So it's I
guess it's just a little bit more
intuitive. Um I'll put a link in the
description if you guys want to read
more about that.
Um what about geospatial indexes in
terms of indexing shapes or polygons? Um
sometimes there are services that kind
of want to be able to you know store a
bunch of polygon data um and you know
put those on a map and that's kind of
how a lot of maps are built out. But
actually speaking they are unlikely to
use geohashes. Um geohashes are mainly
optimized for just kind of indexing
points and being able to find a bunch of
points that are near one another. But if
you actually want to store shapes
themselves, you're better off using this
more complex structure called an R tree.
Um, there are similarities to geohashes,
but at the end of the day, it looks like
in R tries, you can actually have
overlapping boxes, which is not possible
in geohashing. Uh, maybe I'll make a
video about that in the future, but for
now, it's a pretty complex topic and
it's not necessarily something that I
think we need to know.
Okay, so in conclusion, geospatial
indexing is hugely important for any uh
application that's going to hold a ton
of geographic data. As opposed to just
using a typical 2D coordinate in order
to make queries, it hashes these to one
single value, which it can then make
really efficient range queries on. Um,
overall I hope this is pretty helpful
because there are a bunch of systems
design questions that ask you to build
services um that involve ride sharing or
online localized dating or even just
review services but in a localized
manner. And as a result of that, it's
probably pretty important that you know
how geohashes work so you can actually
go ahead and talk about them. Um, as
always, I'll put more data or more
information in the description of the
video so that you guys can read more
about it. Um, but yeah, I hope this one
was useful and I look forward to
continuing to talk about new content.